so i'm here with jeffrey rosen the head
of the national constitution center in
philadelphia and what i want to talk
about in this video jeffrey is how has
uh the powers of the president how have
they changed over time since the the
ratification of a constitution well
they've hugely expanded and it's so
striking that the framers of the
constitution were concerned that
congress would be the most dangerous
branch and they were so concerned about
that that they split congress in two and
created this bicameral legislature the
house and senate in order to divide its
powers
they would have been stunned to learn
that the president is twice as powerful
as congress today uh they created a unit
unitary executive because they were less
concerned about executive than
congressional tyranny and it's really
interesting to think about why that why
that happened
and what do you mean by the president
today is twice as powerful as congress
well i i guess that was a hypothesis but
um
it's arguable that having assumed powers
to deploy troops without congressional
authorization to target and kill
american citizens abroad to engage in
executive orders
without congressional approval
critics of the expansion of presidential
power say that the president has usurped
congressional authority uh he's exceeded
his power under the take care clause of
uh article uh two section three of the
constitution and that in this way
presidential authority has hugely
expanded well congressional authority
has uh contracted
i see and what what are i mean what are
the dynamics that allowed this to happen
over the last several hundred years well
there's a wonderful essay on the
national constitution center's
interactive constitution by william
marshall and it's you can find it if you
click on article 2 section 3 and and
william marshall is trying to figure out
what some of these dynamics were
and he comes up with a bunch of reasons
why the president has been so dominant
first he says political culture the
president has become the focus of
national power and culture in a way that
he wasn't uh in a pre-internet
pre-television uh pre-radio age
and uh this was the case even during
world war ii when justice jackson in the
steel seizure case that we talked about
before talked about executive power
having the advantage of concentration in
a single head and whose choice a whole
nation has a part making them the focus
of public hopes and expectations but
there's no question that the uh focus on
the individual
person of the presidency has vastly
expanded
it's just this idea that there's one
person there people associate that
person hey they are head of state they
put their hopes and fears on that person
that that just gives them inherently
more power it does i i and you know you
can call it culture you can call it uh
celebrity but it's so striking that the
framers are so concerned that the
president not be a king and they reject
alexander hamilton's suggestion which
again we know from the musical that the
president be elected for life they they
want to have uh four-year terms and then
the subsequently a constitutional
amendment has passed the 22nd amendment
to limit the president to only two terms
and despite all that
uh the presidency has expanded so much
it's not only the political culture um
marshall points to a bunch of other uh
reasons uh executive branch precedence
basically every president has been
successful in asserting increasingly
sweeping exercises of executive power
this is a bipartisan phenomenon from
president clinton to george w bush to
president obama the office of legal
counsel in the justice department has uh
authorized increasingly sweeping
exercises of executive authority and we
find presidents of both parties uh
either criticized or praised for having
established these executive branch
presidents
there's also just the expansion and just
to make sure i make sure i understand i
mean it's just this idea that even if if
you were just president i come into
office i might even be more restrained
but then the next guy or or gal that
comes in can cite your presidency and
say hey he did it why shouldn't i be
able to do it so there's this it's it's
never going to go back precedent will
never take you take powers away they'll
only add to them that's exactly right
and this and this really important but
not so well-known office the office of
legal counsel which several supreme
court justices have been the head of um
is basically a mini supreme court for
the executive branch and it issues
opinions about what the president can do
and those opinions are relied on by
subsequent presidents to justify the
expansion of executive power
that's it
um you know not all presidents have
taken this view my i'm writing a book
now about william howard taft who was
the only president who went on to become
chief justice and he thought he had a
very literalist or judicial conception
of the presidency he thought the
president could only do what the
constitution explicitly authorized he
refused to take actions that he thought
weren't authorized by the constitution
and in this sense he gives us a vision
of what a more constitutionally
constrained presidency would look like
but even though he did that as we were
just talking about people who came after
taft could just cite people before taft
and say
absolutely right and taft's predecessor
theodore roosevelt had the most sweeping
conception of the presidency he said the
president can do whatever the
constitution doesn't explicitly forbid
and his stewardship conception of the
presidency definitely has been
vindicated by time and you'd have to say
presidents today are much more roosevelt
dean than they are uh the heirs of
william our taft yeah so what other
dynamics are at play we talk about
political culture that celebrity into
one person this precedent that keeps
expanding powers what else well there's
the huge expansion of the federal
government and the administrative state
and the growth of executive agencies in
the post-new deal period from the
environmental protection agency and even
progressive era agencies like the
federal trade commission or the federal
reserve and uh workplace safety national
park uh management smokestack emissions
college sports there's almost no area of
american life that these executive
agencies don't regulate the president by
appointing the heads of these agencies
and having the ability to fire them can
issue executive orders that have the
force of law even though they're not
passed by congress and that can lead to
really dramatic clashes between uh the
president's use of executive orders and
what congress says that it actually
intended as we've seen during the obama
administration so that's a big factor as
well
yeah and and what other dynamics are are
there well the modern world is moving a
lot faster in an age of the internet and
instant communication there are a lot
more uh emergencies uh attacks are much
more sudden uh than they uh were at the
time of the framing and have to be
repelled more quickly so just the speed
of contemporary life has led to the
president to assert uh new emergency
powers and then finally and i'm just
tracking william marshall's great essay
here there's the rise of partisan
politics because of congress becoming so
polarized often people in congress see
their responsibility to support their
party rather than to take seriously
their constitutional or institutional uh
duties as legislators so they may be
unwilling to
or check the president's power when
their party is in the majority they're
just willing to write the president a
blank check when he happens to be
uh a member of their party um
and i can see that when when it's the
same party in charge of congress and the
president see but what about when it's
the other way around obviously you know
in recent times it seems like the
congress is being very effective at
limiting presidential power well because
of partisans you do have either
congressional inaction or refusal to act
on presidential uh proposals um but
often uh
critics of congressional inaction
complain congress is refusing to
veto bills for example
sorry to override presidential vetoes or
to refuse to pass laws on constitutional
grounds instead they're filing lawsuits
they're kicking things up to the court
when when president obama issued his
executive orders about immigration uh
there was a lawsuit filed so
increasingly the judiciary is becoming
the arbiter about disputes between
congress and the president the framers
expected a much more direct clash
between the president and congress and
thought that both of those uh branches
of government would make decisions on
constitutional grounds and would
directly check each other
it's this idea that instead of congress
passing uh legislation and then
president either signing them or vetoing
them
that when you have this gridlock that
the president starts taking more
executive orders
and then congress takes the president to
court
very well stated and that's definitely
not what the what the framers intended
interesting so this is really fun just
to go over them once again when you just
have one person in charge and this is
you know it starts you know with
washington who who was this you know
huge personality obviously american hero
and then so that that
by itself put a lot of power in the
president
then every president comes along and
maybe does a little bit more
than the ones that came before it and
then anyone can cite that president that
hey he pulled it off why can't i as you
mentioned the federal government is far
far far larger than it was uh in the
time of when the when the constitution
was written and in the time of
washington and and just the speed with
which things are happening
it's necessary for president to whether
it's in war or regulation or other
things to just be able to take action
quickly and then finally
partisan politics i guess you know that
one could it seems that could be debated
either way depending on which parties
are in power where but uh it is
fascinating it does seem like this has
been a very clear trend over time it's
true that that's those are all great
reasons offered by william marshall and
his interactive constitution essay
there's one other factor and that is the
fact that both branches the president
and congress are not evaluating their
actions on constitutional grounds the
way they used to the president has the
veto power under article 1 section 7.
and
in
at the time of the framing the
president's uh often issued vetoes on
constitutional grounds president andrew
jackson who vetoed the rechartering of
the second bank of the united states
vetoed it on the grounds that he could
uh veto any bill that he considered
unconstitutional and he sided with
thomas jefferson's view that the bank
was unconstitutional rejecting the view
of hamilton and george washington that
it was okay but nowadays presidents tend
not to issue vetoes on constitutional
grounds and congress tends not to debate
bills in constitutional terms and as a
result
critics on both sides of the aisle say
both branches are exceeding their
constitutional powers and failing
adequately to check the constitutional
excesses of the other branch
it's fascinating something i never fully
appreciated that what you mentioned
historically you know washington and
adams and jefferson they viewed their
veto as kind of like a light supreme
court a little bit like is this
constitutional or not and that's why
i'll veto it but then later president
started to say no if i just disagree
with it i just think it's a bad law
i will veto absolutely and this idea
that the supreme court is the sole
authority arbiter of constitutional uh
the constitutionality of laws would have
surprised the framers they had a theory
of departmentalism they thought that all
three branches had an obligation to
evaluate the constitutionality of laws
the congress when they passed a bill the
president when he signed it and the
courts when they reviewed it and only
when all three branches agreed could a
law go into effect uh but that uh now we
tend to punt all constitutional
questions to the supreme court and that
has left something of a vacuum on the
side of the president and congress
well thanks so much for this job thank
you